this is hands down the best phone for  gaming however this thing gets  incredibly hot while playing games  especially at 120 fps and because of  that we decided to buy the razer phone  cooler specifically made for the iphone  because of this very special feature  check this out  max 8 and now let's jump into pascal's  wager which as you can see has 120 fps  support right there here's the moment of  truth 100 average fps from the 90 it's  not that big of a difference but the  difference in the cooling alone is  incredible because with the first 10  minute run without the cooler the  display dimmed multiple times and at one  point it got so dim that you could  hardly see the game but with the cooler  man it was staying so cool instead of 44  degrees celsius the hottest point on the  back it was at 36. if you're gonna buy  any phone cooler out there this one is  the one to buy for the iphone 12 series  or the iphone 13 series